I want to ask you this because I think
um you know one of the main components
that kind of
uh people when they think about early
Chicago days we as and not early Chicago
in general because you know we can go
back to like Twista and common and all
that [ __ ] but like in terms of just the
drill movement
um
You Know Chief Keef obviously kicked the
door down
uh I saw you talk about kind of his
influence and what um Charlemagne said
yeah and you're going to see Charlemagne
this weekend shout out to my guy
um I I wonder I know some people had
felt a certain type of way about when
academics was doing the war in Chiraq
[ __ ] around that time you were probably
a lot more present in some of that [ __ ]
yeah was that something that you guys
paid attention to or yeah was it
something you saw added to the violence
yeah it definitely added to the violence
and I'll I got a one-on-one academics
too and we could talk about this you
know what I'm saying Academy's my
brother I'll [ __ ] with him you know what
I'm saying um but we thought academics
was from Chicago
thank you so much yeah yeah he ain't
from Chicago bro right he's speaking on
this [ __ ] in a way where it's like
Jersey got a hood Jersey got a trenches
Jersey got rappers all this you're not
speaking on this [ __ ] because you from
there these people really know you right
I feel like in my opinion you know
you're not gonna speak so much on what's
going on in Jersey even though Chicago
had the bigger Spotlight on him and
there was something to talk about but at
the end of the day you don't know how
many people lost their lives outside of
the internet about some [ __ ] you talk
about right you calling a [ __ ] you
calling Reese the Grim Reaper like a
[ __ ] I want to kill him just because
you call him to say yeah you call a
[ __ ] the Grim Reaper [ __ ] the Grim
Reaper you don't supposed to call no man
the Grim Reaper you feel I'm saying the
Grim Reaper is a representation of death
and you calling this man that they got a
family they got kids they got a mother
they got a sister that people got but he
was young I gave him that I give him
credit he was just on the outside
looking in there was something to talk
about and it built his platform to this
day I'm not gonna knock him for that
right but at the end of the day a lot of
that [ __ ] made a big difference in
what's going on now I promise you we
didn't know who academics was we thought
academics was from Chicago yeah because
he knew so much but that's somebody that
was just in tune with what we doing
because we broadcasted it so we got to
hold ourselves accountable right talking
about it in the music exactly we
broadcasted this [ __ ] so I'm gonna be a
man and say yeah we started it for sure
right we initiated it but at the end of
the day we was just kids and this was
all reality right we didn't ever look at
this [ __ ] like oh we put these guns on
internet we gonna get famous it was just
cameras we were just cameras around
videos [ __ ] started rapping we just
embracing our life as soon as that
camera went down we ain't putting them
guns in storage right [ __ ] was
right on the block with us and we
protecting our life
that's what we was up against and people
got to understand that and a lot of
people lost their life to that and
that's a lot of reasons why people react
and behave the way they do you know what
I'm saying yeah I think I understand
like the uh because I know Vic uh shout
out to Vic uh Vic Mentor like he he was
not I mean I know a lot of people who
have you know negative connotations
towards academics rightfully so a lot of
people do but I think at that time I I
don't know if he understood the gravity
of what he was doing I will give him no
I will give him the benefit to say he
didn't understand what he was doing and
at that time I'm not sure he ever knew
he'd be
on camera yeah like we know academics is
like a personality in hip-hop as to
where like then he was just the voice
that was just you know kind of narrating
on camera about yeah nobody knew how he
looked when he was doing that he didn't
show his face right and I think that's
one of the reasons why he didn't he
didn't want nobody to know how he looked
right he didn't want nobody know who he
was because the [ __ ] he was doing bro
yeah I ain't gonna lie and you gotta I'm
gonna talk I'm gonna talk to him when we
say that for real like you gotta really
hold yourself accountable for what
you've done and the same responsible for
a lot of this [ __ ] the same way that we
are as artists I think that's important
is the I think I think
anybody who's a grown ass man look man
if you were 19 20 making YouTube videos
you should at least own whatever you
want to own it I was 19 20 and you I'm
talking about the [ __ ] I'm up against or
18 17 but I wasn't talking about nothing
and if I want somebody to go outside and
kill somebody and even I'm talking about
some [ __ ] cause I just seen my best
friend get his [ __ ] head blown up
it's crazy even just the influence of
like those videos like because now
there's so many YouTube channels and
their whole shtick is talking over
clips that we don't know what these
people look like we just know that
they're covering whatever City's
[ __ ] that's going on like it'd be
hard for me to touch on it because it's
so close to home of course man it's a
sensitive subject if I'm saying like I
lost a lot of people that I really love
it's crazy it's not I mean like you said
it's behind the streets bro you feel